Hallo, mein Name ist Sabrina Wallace, und meine Eltern waren beide 1969 Teil der Space Force.
Ich habe zufällig einen hübschen Kristall in einer ähnlichen Form.
Nun, viele Leute sagen gerne Dinge, die wir nicht unbedingt gerne ansprechen, um den Leuten zu helfen, Dinge zu verstehen, die schwer zu verstehen sind, weil, wissen Sie, gerade alle damit beschäftigt sind, sich auf den Drohnenkrieg vorzubereiten, den elektromagnetischen Drohnenkrieg.
Wir haben es im Irak gemacht und dann kurz davor und wissen Sie, das Land wird auf die eine oder andere Weise in den Krieg ziehen.
Ob es nun, wissen Sie, unsere eigenen Leute oder etwas anderes sein werden oder nicht, wir haben in den Vereinigten Staaten ein ernstes Lerndefizit.
Ob es konstruiert und entworfen wurde oder nicht.
Ich lasse andere Leute darüber reden.
Was ich heute tun werde, ist, Ihnen genau zu zeigen, was Sie Ihren eigenen Kindern erklären müssen, damit wir die Mundstilrevolution vermeiden können.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass sie tatsächlich wütend werden.
Und das werden wir mit Bildung machen.
Also fange ich an.
Das sind wir nicht.
Mein Name ist Sabrina Wallace.
Ich bin ein Kind eines Austin.
Und meine Familienmitglieder sind an schwarzen Projekten beteiligt, an Seps-Sonderprojekten.
Ich bin also BAIER-Mitglied und mein Großvater ist Bernard Heinrichs hier, und dieser Name ist Mr.
Er heiratete Helen Harding, und Helen Harding ist direkt mit Pius Levi verwandt.
Mein Vater war Steven Garland Davis.
Meine Mutter ist Lynne Gene Scheer.
Sie sind beide geheim Central Super.
1969 arbeitete ich im Rahmen der Menninger Foundation Experimentation for Human Augmentation am Projekt Silence, I Am a Modified Child.
Das bedeutet nur, dass ich Narben habe, die die meisten Menschen nicht für die Architektur von John von Neumann haben.
Es ist keine Schnittstelle zwischen Gehirn und Maschine.
Es ist Körpermasse.
Das ist unmöglich.
Und es klingt Was nochmal?
Ich bleibe dran.
Also hier ist die Hochzeitsliste meiner Eltern.
Okay.
Hier sind die Fluglisten von Edgewood Arsenal für meinen Großonkel.
65/70 Armeechemikalie, Fort Dietrich.
Wohin?
Texas.
New York, Nordkorea.
Nur einer ist nicht gut genug.
Eleanor Hall Es ist immer noch für die drei.
Ich bin wahrscheinlich hier, war an den Mothman-Projekten und dem Bau von Fahrzeugen für die Men in Black beteiligt.
Nun, die Schnittstelle für John von Neumann-Narben befindet sich direkt darunter.
Ich sehe dort einen.
Und natürlich bin ich jetzt älter, aber das ist dein Herz.
Okay, das ist also eine Body-Machine-Schnittstelle mit einer unterirdischen Datenbank namens Next the longer, die IBM ist.
Also habe ich es in meinem Deutschunterricht an der High School falsch buchstabiert.
Nick ist dort auf der rechten Seite gefallen.
Okay.
Warum ist das wichtig?
Denn wenn Leute solche Dinge sagen, sollten sie dir besser Beweise vorlegen können, brauchbare Beweise, sonst würde ich ihnen nicht zuhören.
Okay, hier ist ein bisschen mehr Dokumentation, und dann werden wir weitermachen und mit der intellektuellen Diskussion beginnen.
Okay.
Also hier sind meine Familie und Garland hier.
Mein Großvater, Garland Davis, ein Marine aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Fort Meade, NSA.
Mm hmm.
Und zuerst heiratete er Elizabeth Kraft.
Aber ich glaube, etwas mit der DNA hat nicht geklappt.
Dann hat er meine Mutter geheiratet.
Tante.
Okay.
Du hast also für eine Firma gearbeitet, die meine Eltern und mein Großonkel waren.
Oh, tut mir leid.
Eins habe ich vergessen.
Mein Onkel, mein Großonkel ist da, wo ich wohne.
Also ist er.
Er war schon immer einer meiner Lieblingsmenschen.
Es ist ein sehr netter Mann.
Oh, komm schon.
Diesmal hatte ich alles richtig in der Geschichte.
Okay.
Oh.
So südlich.
Ich habe also eine ganz andere Geschichte als meine Eltern.
Mir wurde nie etwas gesagt.
Nichts.
Also bin ich aufgewachsen und wollte es.
Und sie sagten mir, dass nichts existiert außer dem, was man sehen könnte.
Und ich wollte wissen, was all das elektromagnetische Zeug ist?
Ich bin in den Achtzigern, in den Neunzigern aufgewachsen.
Ich wurde 1979 geboren, und wenn Sie über die Aura sprachen, haben Sie alle in die Ecke gedrängt und verlangt, dass Sie sich ihrer Lesergruppe anschließen.
Und ich habe immer da gesessen und gesagt, dir ist klar, dass es ein Körperteil ist.
Und ich mag, Nein, du bist dämlich.
Du musst eine Religion haben.
Mir war nie klar, was ich war.
Ich wusste nicht, warum sich die Leute so dämlich verhalten, zum Beispiel warum würdest du über ein Körperteil lügen?
Und doch waren meine Eltern geheime Eichhörnchen.
Das sind vier Strafverfolgungsebenen, die über allem stehen, was Zivilisten sehen.
Und sie sind der Ex.
Die geheime Elite.
Was?
Es ist ein geheimer Elitedienst.
Und das ist so ziemlich alles.
Sobald du da bist, ist das geheime Strafverfolgung.
Im Moment musst du noch ein Level höher gehen.
Okay, jetzt muss ich noch ein Level höher gehen.
Sie meinen es ernst.
Ja, ich kann noch ein Level höher gehen.
Richtig.
Also machte ich weiter und arbeitete für eine Firma in Louisville, Kentucky, namens High Speed Access.
Und zu diesem Zeitpunkt schickten sie mir meine Unterlagen zur Arbeit, damit sie sie genau dort sehen konnten.
Sie haben nur ihren alten Erwachsenen das Schwitzen erwischt.
Das ist für uns die Rückkehr ins All.
Das eigentliche Hinterland dieses Landes.
Ich war einer von zwei Technikern, die den Bundesstaat Wisconsin von der Einwahl bis zum Breitband verkabelt haben.
Ich bin mir also ganz klar.
L-3 Harris oder C 24, all die verschiedenen Arten, wie wir mit allen Arten von Informationen umgehen, dem PRISM-Programm der NSA, alles einschließlich Datengrammpaketen.
Netzwerktechnik ist nicht dasselbe wie die Installation eines Kabelmodems.
Ich muss mit dem Anlagentechniker und dem Anlageningenieur zusammenarbeiten.
Da mietet niemand eine Fabrik.
Und in dieser Position von mir gab es niemanden, der eingestellt wurde, außer dem, den ich tue.
Ja, ich war 19.
Also für den internationalen Tourismus, so dass, während ich hier weitermache und die Leute mir wirklich nichts zu sagen hatten, weil ich genau da bin, wo ich dir sage, dass ich bin.
Ganzkörper.
Verzeihen Sie meinen dreckigen Fuß.
In Ordnung, also, Schwester.
Lass uns sehen.
Ich fragte technische Dienste, professionelles UW Whitewater überwachtes Campus-Netzwerk, verschiedene Softwarepakete, darunter viel Gold in Maps-Netzwerk, Vintage-HP, offene Ansicht in kurzen Interaktionen mit Snort.
Zu den Operationen der zweiten Schicht gehören die Verarbeitung von Datenbanken mit PeopleSoft, acht aktualisierte Codierungsrouter und Switches, die Arbeit mit Visio, um eine Glasfaserkarte des Campus zu erstellen, initiierte Schulungen.
Ganz einfach, es ist natürlich ein ganzer Staat wie ein kleiner Brocken.
Als ich zum Network Operations Center in Louisville ging, oder wollte ich mir einen dieser Netzwerkberater bei Omni Resources in Green Bay aufbauen.
Problematische Betriebssystemkonflikte, Studentenprobleme, Shock West-Konflikte.
Das proprietäre Unternehmen entwickelte Software, assistierte mit Cisco Fixed Firewall Stuff Programm Assistant to Department of Corrections Wales, Wisconsin Installierte und implementierte Inhouse Tracking Program Facility Maintenance Department of Ethan Allen School for Boys Entwickeln Datenbanken und Zugriff und geben eine Anleitung für Oracle Implementierung Fehlerbehebung von Netzwerk- und Desktop-Problemen innerhalb der Abteilungen und ein großer Job.
Oktober 1999 bis Mai 22, Charter Communications wartete ein Upgrade und unterrichtete und Fehler beheben ISP-Netzwerk, bestehend aus Cisco drei Kong Comm 21 und Bay Networks hatte fünf installierte Racks und hatte in der Saison.
Das Management von Colin Cable, verantwortlich für den wöchentlichen und monatlichen Bericht, einige Bandbreite- und Stromkreisnutzungstests, zurückgegebene Kabelmodems, Garantie- oder Umstellungsprobleme, leichte Abdeckung, Verantwortungsbereich für über 12.000 Kunden, installierte und wartete Cisco AC 5300-Server für sieben separate Pools, überwachte die Bandbreite in konfigurierten Cisco 7200-Routern mit Upgrades für 9000 Kunden und verwaltet die Beziehungen zwischen Kabelbetreiber und Technikern in Plainfield, Illinois, während im Januar 2001 neue Mitarbeiter in den technischen und administrativen Positionen geschult wurden.
Schauen Sie sich die Softwareliste an und das ist etwas, das 2004 dauerhaft deaktiviert wurde, weil sie von ihrer eigenen Regierung deprimiert wurde.
Um die Tür zu schließen, sagte ich: Gehen Sie immer noch telepathisch nach Projekten?
Weißt du, vielleicht nicht, aber inzwischen wird es Spaß machen.
Von hier aus werden wir also einen Spaziergang in die Realität von heute im Jahr 2022 machen.
Und zuerst werden wir eine kleine Lektion aus der Vergangenheit ziehen.
In meinem Job, als ich bei UW Whitewater gearbeitet habe.
Sie hat einen riesigen Magneten unter sich in einem festen Satelliten mit niedriger Erdumlaufbahn über sich.
Und in den siebziger Jahren hatte UW Whitewater eine Menge Software, die für all diese unterirdischen Nick Furlong-, IBM-Datenbanken und dergleichen herumlag.
Sie sind unterirdisch.
Also das ist kein Vielleicht, das ist eine Gewissheit.
Es hat mehr als alles andere mit Kühlung zu tun.
Also nochmal, als Kind wuchs ich damit auf, Dinge wie diese zu zeichnen, weil sie die Gehirn-Gehirn-Schnittstelle auf synthetische Telepathie getestet haben.
Und die Menschen wurden schon lange über diesen elektromagnetischen Körperteil belogen.
Und jetzt befinden wir uns in einer Krise in unserem Land.
Das ist von 1993, und so funktionieren die ZigBee-Bluetooth-Layouts.
So sehen sie aus.
Und genau so werden sie auch in der Telekommunikation abgewickelt.
Und das alles werde ich mir zeigen.
Aber ich möchte darauf hinweisen, dass sie an Kindern getestet wurden.
Ja, das macht unsere Regierung.
Die Eltern, meine Eltern, sie übergeben dich einfach.
Das ist ihr Job.
Es ist ein geheimer Einsatz für Synchron.
Nee.
Tut mir leid, Leute.
Nein, darauf komme ich gleich zurück.
Diese Reise für mich begann also als Kind mit Scanner-Action Issues, was wirklich nur bedeutet, dass ich die Kontrolle über meine gesamte Physiologie hatte, anstatt den Leuten um mich herum zuzuhören, die mir eine Geschichte erzählen, die mir erzählt, wie ich mich davon abhalten kann, einfach meinen eigenen Körper zu fühlen.
Und als ich ab 1979 aufgewachsen bin, fand ich es immer bizarr, ungewöhnlich, aber ich wusste es nicht.
Mir war nicht bewusst, dass das Herzstück der Überwachung die menschlichen Biofilme sind.
Und als ich es einmal getan hatte, war das nicht okay.
Und meine Familie zwang mich, für fast ein Jahrzehnt wegzugehen, weil ich von Perch aus nie etwas sagen durfte.
Chris Es sind die Herbstjahre.
Im Jahr 2019 hatte ich einen Kontakt mit einem Engländer namens Ambulance, und am Telefon sagte der Typ im Krankenwagen: Bring sie zum Hubschrauberlandeplatz, bring sie zur Lodge, bring sie zur Farm.
Jetzt bin ich einfach nur noch von der Regierung gerettet.
Es war das erste Mal, dass ich einen Krankenwagen gerufen habe.
Darauf war ich nicht vorbereitet.
Und dann wusste ich, dass das Militär mich beobachtete.
Und dann wusste ich von einem Fehler, den unsere Defense Intelligence Agency über meine Eltern feststellte.
Nicht wirklich.
Ich arbeite hier für Charter, kann aber Radar und all diese anderen elektromagnetischen Signale senden.
Das ist natürlich.
Der Hund reagiert genauso wie ich.
Das sagen wir den Leuten nicht, es sei denn, Sie sind im Marine Corps, um sich der Situation bewusst zu werden.
Jetzt verwenden Stingray und Dirt Bikes dasselbe Körperteil, weil es elektromagnetisch ist.
Und 1953, der Großonkel, dann brachte er eine Menge Bilder und elektromagnetische Drohnen mit nach Hause und 1953 und wieder, Mama und Papa 1969, die am Projekt Salus arbeiteten, das jeden molekularen Zustand kontrolliert, den wir innerhalb und außerhalb des menschlichen Körpers haben.
Wenn Sie sich jetzt Zellen ansehen, werden sie Ihnen Logistik und Bewegung und im Grunde alles international nach Molekülen sagen.
Und du sagst, das ist unmöglich.
Das liegt daran, dass Sie nichts über das Nano-Internet der Dinge, das industrielle Internet der Dinge, wissen und dass es viele dieser Maschinenschnittstellensysteme 1958 gab.
Warum würdest du es den Leuten nicht sagen?
Ich meine, Edgewood Arsenal.
Wir testen es an unseren eigenen Soldaten.
Wieder Vietnam mit meinem Großvater.
Wir haben 1953 elektromagnetische Drohnen.
Was ist los?
Richtig.
Also bin ich hierher nach West Virginia gekommen und die Seltsamkeit mit dem Krankenwagen und dann geht es weiter.
Noch mehr Seltsamkeit, verschwindende Fahrzeuge.
Ich gehe also in die Buchhandlungen und sie haben diese Frage.
Oh, wir planen für die Grafschaft.
Ich bin Hausbesitzer, also habe ich hier in einer Stadt mit 200 Einwohnern 60 neueste Dinge gebaut.
Sie wurden entführt.
Scheint komisch.
Hm.
Das brachte mich dazu, sechs Glo-Pins zu erforschen, und da ich aus Netzwerktechnik und Cybersicherheit gekommen bin, ist einer meiner Lieblingsorte, weil ich mathematische Umgebungen mache, und das musste auch, weil ich das Backend der Space Forces an Vierpunktadressen subnetzen musste, die letztes Jahr in Florida verkauft wurden.
Wirklich interessant.
Aber das habe ich auch herausgefunden.
Wie dem auch sei, wenn Sie Netzwerktechniker sind und für Ihren Cisco Certified Network Associate studieren, mussten Sie damals ein Subnetz in Binärform erstellen, weil wir nicht genug IP-Adressen hatten.
Also ja, ich habe binomiale Mathematik gelesen.
Das war früher Teil meines Jobs.
Okay.
Also, wenn es um Cybersicherheit geht, ist das Zeug in diesem ersten Teil total voll von einfach so langweiligen Dingen, wie den Seitenschichten und dem Internet und so.
Also nochmal, wenn Sie ein Subnetz aufbauen und Ihre Kunden isolieren müssen und Sie bestimmten Tausenden von Menschen verpflichtet sind und sie Sie für 300.000$ pro Minute Verlust festnageln, dann ist das zu diesem Zeitpunkt Charter-Kommunikation.
Dann musst du wissen, was du tust und du kannst dich nicht irren.
400 Riesen in einer Minute.
Ja, es ist ein gewisser Druck, unter dem du in so einem Job stehst.
Denken Sie daran, dass es im ganzen Bundesstaat nur zwei Personen gibt, die mit dieser Ausrüstung umgehen können.
Du darfst also nicht in Urlaub fahren.
Du musst im Grunde ein Babysitterprogramm machen.
Ja.
Also Netzwerksicherheit, 60 Low-Personal Area Network.
Und sie wird von Maschine zu Maschine fahren, was bedeutet, dass keine Menschen an einem Ad-hoc-Fahrzeug beteiligt sind.
Beachten Sie zum Beispiel, hier ist ein Stürmer, hier ist eine Drohne.
Jetzt habe ich ein paar Probleme.
Zuallererst können Sie die Drohne nicht unterbrechen.
Die Pentagon-Erklärung 3000.09 behauptet vor über 11 Jahren und Sie können dies auf CSR finden.
Zum Beispiel sagte das Pentagon im Mai dieses Jahres 2022, ich denke, dass unsere Kommandeure vor Ort in der Lage sein müssen, das maschinelle Lernen zu lesen.
Nun, es ist klar, dass der Kommandant, der Ehemann, insbesondere der Kommandant, am 10.
September 2020 nicht am Symposium für künstliche Intelligenz teilgenommen haben.
Wenn der Commander das getan hätte, wüsste er, dass dies kein digitales Nervensystem von Ende zu Ende ist, ohne dass Menschen an, ich zitiere, Projekt Selous beteiligt waren.
Was haben wir aus der Produktlieferung gelernt?
Gib ihnen den Code.
Die Salus-Plattform wird für NORTHCOM verwendet, wobei Upgrades an Anbieter vergeben werden.
Der Game Changer ist, dass sich die neuen neuronalen Prototypprodukte in der Entwicklung befinden und hier erhältlich sind.
Also was?
Für den Anfang neuer neuronaler Prototyp Synchro, die G Joint Artificial Intelligence.
Was Fuzing ist, ist eine Fuzing-Organisation, die sich darauf konzentriert, Produkte an Menschen weiterzuverkaufen, die sie tatsächlich verwenden.
Dann stritten sie sich darüber, ob es sich um hybridisierte oder digitalisierte Netzwerkdienste von Amazon handeln sollte, und Microsoft und Amazon sagten, oder gaben mir einen Regierungsvertrag.
Okay.
Dann wurde es für mich noch seltsamer.
Und während ich zuhöre, sagten sie Datenkennzeichnungsdienste.
Und ich denke, das ist eine riesige Datenbankdatenkuration.
Und ich denke an den Verkäufer, den Kunden und ich geschrieben haben: Das ist das Verteidigungsministerium.
Dafür können Sie hier bis zum Anfang gehen und dort steht, dass das Team von Jake, ich meine die Joint Artificial Intelligence Commission, ihre Rolle darin besteht, KI zu entwickeln.
real und jeder kann und sollte künstliche Intelligenz in allem, was er tut, implementieren.
Kunden im gesamten DOD.
Was sind Ihre Kunden?
Schau dir das an.
Contrasting Tools steht also unter dem Dach von Tradewinds und dem Projekt Maven und ich zitiere heiße Leitungen mit intelligenten Sensoren, Biosensors Wireless Working Group 82.1 5.5 Wireless Sensor Networks Specialized Working Group for the International Standards of Electronics and Engineering, entschuldigen Sie mich, Elektronik und Elektrotechnik.
Und Project Maven benutzt Pathfinder und mich, um dir zuzusehen, wie du herumläufst und in deinem Haus in Echtzeit nachdenkst.
Und lassen Sie uns das Projekt MQ Nine Tethered to Ground zitieren.
Das ist die Direktive 3000.09 des Verteidigungsministeriums, in der erneut bekräftigt wurde, dass der Kommandant schlecht gelaunt war, weil er sagte, wir können diese Maschinen nicht hören, wir können sie ihrer Natur nach nicht dekodieren und wir können kein Signal durchlassen.
Und ich zitiere hier am Gate, wir müssen dafür sorgen, dass das Air Force-System von IBM besser mit allem anderen zusammenhängt.
Wir werden ein digitales Nervensystem von Ende zu Ende schaffen.
Wir müssen im DOD neu überdenken, wie wir alle Plattformen von IBM verbinden können.
Was kontrollieren sie?
Plattformen für Lesben, Autonome Fahrzeuge.
Du meinst autonome Drohnen, Panzer, normale Stryker, alles Mögliche.
Flugzeuge, guck mal.
Was ist mit etwas anderem?
Absolut.
Das industrielle Internet der Dinge in den Milliarden, die über selbstfahrende Fahrzeuge verfügen und alles aus alliierter Luft besteht.
Aber Sie dachten, das sei nur für den intelligenten Teil, Sie sollten sich mit der HF-Technik befassen, eine neue Methode zur Rettung der Lage namens Green Road.
Es ist keine neue Spezialfaser entlang der Autobahn.
Auf die Frage, könnten Sie einfach ein bisschen Licht gebrauchen, um auf die bergige Seite zu ziehen, das ist Ort, Monarchen und Sonderzugang, Curtis National Institute of Science and Technology für die Regierung, es bezahlen Leute, das ist kein Witz, schwarze Projekte, denken Sie daran, ich zahle nicht wirklich 45 Grand für einen ganzen Toilettensitz.
Nein, tun sie nicht.
Aber weißt du was?
Sie machen die fiesen Iris.
Damit die Leute einen solchen Stapel haben, müssen sie fünf Codes eingeben, um zu verstecken, wohin das ganze Geld fließt, und die Ressourcenzuweisung und die Logistik und den Versand, und dann die Neuzuweisung von Leuten für spezielle Zugangsprojekte und dann die Umverteilung derjenigen, die dafür verantwortlich sind, sie zu bewachen, sie zu verfolgen, sie zu verfolgen, oder das Verteidigungsministerium zu einer Liste für Änderungen an Sonderzugriffsprojekten.
Es gerät außer Kontrolle und es ist alles Open Source und Sie können darüber lesen und es bei Google nachschlagen.
Das ist also unser Problem hier.
Also willst du mir erklären, was diese Biosensoren sind und wovon du sprichst?
Eine MQ Nine Reaper-Drohne.
Es ist mit meiner DNA verbunden.
Was ist los?
Und übrigens, wer sind Ihre Kunden?
Eigentlich.
Cybersicherheit.
Ja.
Erstes Symposium über künstliche Intelligenz.
Sie sagten ihnen, dass alle Menschen nicht im Weg sind, also sollte ich es so formulieren, dass eins bis Ende zum digitalen Nervensystem für diese Plattformen, die mit den Menschen verbunden sind, aus dem Prozess heraus und in die Argumentation, dem aktuellen Manager ermöglichen, direkt datenwissenschaftliche Kreditzellen zu verwenden und.
Seit ich ein Kind war.
Interviews mit Maschinenschnittstellen.
Quantendatenbanken.
Korrelation zwischen Managern.
Warum sollten sie das tun?
Das neue 60 Personal Area Network wird also Ihren Körper verwenden, um die Daten weiterzuleiten.
Und bevor du denkst, oh nein, sie würden uns sagen, dass das 2005 gemacht wurde.
Das ist das drahtlose Sensornetzwerk.
Die Biosensoren sind im Grunde permanent und lebenslang seit 2005 und seit 2005 mit Zigbee und Bluetooth, worüber ich mich schon beschwert habe, als ich ihn reingeschickt habe, ich war noch ein Kind.
Warum sehen Zigbee und Bluetooth und diese Biosensoren genau so aus?
Weil es so funktioniert.
Die internationalen Normen für Elektronik und Elektrotechnik verwenden ein Wide Body Area Network und 82.1 5.6 Electronic Standards for Wireless Working Group Wide Body Area Network 82.1 5.6.
Und das sind die vier Kreise, in denen sie beschreiben, was sie mit deinem Körper tun können.
Und wie immer, weißt du, sollten wir keine Querschnittsgelähmten mehr haben und so.
Sie können deine Hände bewegen.
Sie überwachen die Dichte Ihres Muskelgewebes.
Sie können dich zum Reden bringen.
Das können sie.
Und das tun sie gerade.
Sie überwachen all diese Dinge drahtlos.
Wie ist das möglich, wenn dein Körper ein Wearable braucht oder benutzt er deinen Router oder benutzt er deinen Switch wie in oder benutzt er deinen Router oder benutzt er etwas anderes?
Ich wollte es wissen, also habe ich es herausgefunden.
Angesichts der neuen Cybersicherheit hier mit dem Stryker und sie muss Maschine zu Maschine sein, genau wie das Symposium auf der DIA de sagte.
Das Problem ist, dass Autonomie ein leeres N9 ist, das an Ihre DNA gebunden ist, und dass DNA ein elektromagnetisches Körperteil erzeugt.
Und niemand weiß davon.
Sie nennen es die Aura, sie nennen es alles Mögliche.
Oh, es sind UFOs.
Wir wissen es nicht.
Ja, das tun wir.
Skunkworks, Raytheon.
Ich habe dir gerade das Bild gezeigt.
Die Drohnen-Leute können mehr als 40 Jahre arbeiten und wirklich, wirklich bezahlt werden.
Nun.
Wir lassen dich im Dunkeln tappen.
Cybersicherheit, Militär, Sie wissen schon, nationale Sicherheit.
Oh, es ist UFO Skunkworks, Raytheon, Lockheed.
Jeder weiß das.
Sie sind Verkäufer.
Also, was ist das ganze Zeug über psychische Aufzeichnungen?
Wissenschaftler.
Sie sind dem menschlichen Gewebe inhärent.
Es gab also ein Buch, das meine Schüler immer gelesen haben, als ich als Kind darüber unterrichtete.
Hier ist es 1996.
Dieses Buch wurde geschrieben.
Es heißt Integrale Psychologie.
Und im Inneren wirst du das finden, was ich gerade über Telepathie, Empathie, Präkognition und all das gesagt habe.
Es ist bestimmten Bereichen des Gehirns zugeordnet.
Sind diese Sensornetzwerke also bis auf den Nanobereich reduziert?
Dann setzen sie es auf eine proprietäre Software, wenn sie für Zigbee und Bluetooth für diese permanenten lebenslangen Biosensoren schreiben müssen und, wissen Sie, 2.1, 5.4, sie werden dauerhaft an Ihrem Körper befestigt, wo.
Von den Radiofrequenzsynchronisationen.
Es gibt zwei davon.
Sie werden die gesamte elektromagnetische Energie, einschließlich der Potenzierung von Mineralien, aus Ihrem biochemischen Blutkreislauf ziehen und sie umwandeln, weil Ihr elektromagnetisches Feld hier, das Sie für wertlos hielten, nicht existierte und alle sich über Sie lustig gemacht haben.
Es wandelt tatsächlich alles elektromagnetisch auf.
Jetzt verwenden wir synthetisches Radio.
Dies ist ein softwaredefiniertes Radio.
Synthetische Telepathie, nur um deine Haut zu erregen.
Ein wenig elektromagnetisch ein- und ausgeleitet, mit Ihren eigenen Körperteilen.
Also, wie glaubst du, sind sie wach?
Computerdaten?
Auf die gleiche Weise.
Die Biosensoren sind buchstäblich Magnete.
Sie sind repariert und an die Spannung angepasst.
Anleitung zur drahtlosen Arbeitsgruppe ADA 2.15.5.
Und das ist Ihr persönliches Netzwerk.
Dies ist auch Ihr persönliches Netzwerk.
Meine Zeit, wie Sie hier sehen können, haben die sechs G Maupin möglicherweise ein Body-Area-Network für Sicherheitsrouting-Zwecke oder auch nicht.
Sie leiten ihre Daten durch Ihr Gewebe, und ich zitiere einen digitalen Informationsaustausch, der die elektrische Leitfähigkeit des menschlichen Körpers als Datennetzwerk nutzt.
Warum brauchen wir also keinen Gehirnchip?
Weil du seit 6000 Jahren drahtlos bist.
Chinesische Medizin, die Meridiane, Chakren, das sind Knotenpunkte in Ihrem Körper, elektroelektromagnetische Telemetrie.
Also wurden die permanenten Biosensoren in den Jahren 82.1, 5.4 für alle hier oben eingeführt, und sie mussten permanent für Zigbee und Bluetooth sein, und das ist es, was sie bietet.
Und dann kümmert sich die drahtlose Arbeitsgruppe Meter 2.1, 5.5 um all die verschiedenen Arten von Netzwerken, sammelt dann bestimmte Sensoren von nur bestimmten Stellen, öffnet den kürzesten Weg, zuerst Routing-Protokolle oder sicherheitsrelevante Gründe.
Aber wenn sie sie mit Zigbee und Bluetooth erstellen, müssen sie auch den Muskelgewebetyp auswählen.
Seit 2008 müssen sie die Hitze so wählen, dass man den Tod nicht riecht.
Und so haben sie bis 2011, 2013, daran gearbeitet.
Und jetzt haben sie etwa 13 verschiedene Routing-Protokolle, aber nur etwa drei davon sind so konzipiert, dass sie Sie vor den Informationen schützen, die Sie durch die Weiterleitung von Daten durch Ihren Körper erhalten, der dafür Mineralien aus Ihren roten Blutkörperchen zieht.
Jetzt ist es eine sehr kleine Level-Zero-Notice, bis zu viele Unternehmen diese Statistiken gleichzeitig mathematisch heranziehen.
Und so sieht das aus.
Genau hier in unserem kleinen Beispiel möchten Sie vielleicht auch beachten, dass diese beiden aus sechs bestehen, aus denen jeweils fünf Knoten herausragen, genau hier beschriftet wurden und eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf.
Für jeden kleinen Punkt hat man also fünf weitere und sie sind alle elektromagnetisch über die Cloud kommerziell mit Zigbee und Bluetooth zugänglich, was wiederum, du weißt schon, 2.1, 5.4 ist, denn wenn sie es nicht wären, könnten sie Zigbee und Bluetooth nicht in der Wand verkaufen.
Sie hätten die Alexa nicht auf diese Weise benutzen können.
All diese verschiedenen Dinge kommunizieren mit diesen Sensornetzwerken, und sie werden alle von Datenbanken mit künstlicher Intelligenz gesteuert und sind alle miteinander verknüpft.
Wenn Sie also drahtlos sind und sich in derselben WLAN-Arbeitsgruppe wie Ihr Telefon befinden, was eigentlich, Sie wissen schon, 2.1 ist.
In einem großen Personal Area Network leiten sie ihre Daten also über Sie weiter.
Seit 2005 und ich kann eine App dafür schreiben und dann kann ich so mit dir spielen, weil diese hier seit 2005 zugänglich sind.
Glaubst du, die Leute hatten nicht genug Zeit, um synthetische Telepathie und Wearables zu kaufen?
Es ist alles geschrieben.
Und falls ihr nicht wüsstet, dass das Schreiben einer App nicht schwer ist und GitHub sie mit einer sogenannten strukturierten Abfragesprache gestaltet, hey, was ist, fragt euch an das Backend von Microsoft, Apache und WordPress und fragt euch alle, Hallo, das ist der Hadoop of Style.
Also diese Leute in den neunziger Jahren, bevor das 2005 eingeführt wurde, und mit diesen Leuten meine ich meine meine Eltern, geheimes Eichhörnchen, geheime Strafverfolgung, all das Zeug wieder für wen wieder Space Force seit 1969 signalisiert, Nachrichtendienste usw..
Okay, sie haben ein sogenanntes Brain-Gehirn-Interface, eine synthetische Telepathie, und sie ist frequenzgesteuert von Peer-to-Peer.
Ja.
Und sie setzen an ihrem Schreibtisch einen Helm auf und können direkt durch menschliches Gewebe cruisen.
Auch diese Dinge werden in Echtzeit überwacht.
Sag uns, ob das nicht schlimm genug war.
Sie haben Sie auch nach allen Sammlungsdatenbanken geordnet, die Sie hier aufgelistet sehen.
Also der Fernseher, all deine Sinne, Radar, Doppler und dann fliegen die Dreckkisten über deinem Kopf und sie kommunizieren mit der Stingray-Software, die für die einzelnen Sheriff-Abteilungen geschrieben ist, je nachdem, welche Art von Datenbanken sie abonnieren wollen.
Am Ende haben Sie also drei Leichen, die die Straße entlang laufen.
Es gibt zwei Leichen in einem Haus.
Diese Körper werden jetzt von demselben Fahrer benutzt, weil ihre Körper zufällig die beste Maschinensicherheit bieten.
Die Maschine verwendet nur diese Kriterien und sie werden aufgelistet, wenn Sie die Maschine durchlesen und lernen möchten, die Reihenfolge zu beobachten.
Und dann der Schlüssel zur Trennung, wie oft sie den Knoten treffen, wie lange sie warten, 0,06 Sekunden Verzögerung.
Und bei der Cybersicherheit ist es für alles dasselbe.
Hallo.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Intermittierend.
Warte, bleib.
Und wenn Sie etwas über Daten-Hacking mit Paketen wirklich wissen und nicht nur über softwaredefiniertes Enterprise Cloud-Zeug, das heißt und hauptsächlich Software verwenden, meine ich, wie auf der Hardwareseite, sie ziehen das gesamte Paket bis zur physischen Mac-Adressschicht Ihres Körpers auseinander.
Das ist das Problem, in dem wir uns befinden.
Deshalb sind wir hier bis zur letzten Sekunde.
Sie sind mit ihrem Knochenmark verdrahtet.
Und Cisco McCann versorgt alles, was sie im Smart Grid umgibt, mit Strom, wenn Sie gehen, tanzen und wenn Sie sich bewegen.
Und das ist ein weiterer Teil, über den Sie in Eight, 2.1, 5.5 und Wide Body Area Networks 802.15.6 nachlesen können.
Also nochmal, das Problem, auf das wir stoßen, ist, dass, wenn drei Körper die Straße entlang laufen, diese beiden jetzt Tonnen von Signalen abfeuern, die einem sagen, dass jeder Knoten fünf weitere ist.
Jetzt werden all diese Sensoren verrückt.
Diese Person hier, die Maschine wählt diese Person hier aus, die DNA, deine DNA, deinen Körper.
Dadurch entsteht das sichere Signal, das die Drohne verwendet, um Ihre DNA zu verbreiten.
Und genau so funktioniert es.
Um also zu verhindern, dass diese Drohne etwas abfeuert, müssen Sie verhindern, dass sich Ihre DNA ausbreitet.
Warum sollten sie das tun?
Also ein letztes Mal.
Wenn du Pech hast und jemand mit einer Biowaffe getroffen wird.
Das ist elektrische Übertragung über die offene drahtlose Arbeitsgruppe der Wide Body Area Networks.
Es ist also egal, woran du glaubst.
Und das hat es nie getan.
Das haben sie alles genau hier gemacht.
Ihr wart beide Hellseher.
Und dann, wenn sie Menschen transduzierten und sie tatsächliche Tests durchführen, nämlich drahtloses Tissue Engineering und drahtlose totale piezoelektrische Steuerung, neuronale Abschwächung zur Verhaltensmodulation.
Wir schädigen das Gehirn.
Du meinst sehr subtile nanoskalige Bereiche deines Gehirns, um dein Verhalten unter Kontrolle zu halten.
Dann schicken wir Sie zu Menschen und sagen Ihnen, dass kognitive Verhaltenstherapie Ihnen helfen wird, wenn Puma künstliche Intelligenz benötigt.
Wir wissen, wenn du es immer und immer wieder sagst, wirst du es tun.
Warum sollten sie also Ihre epigenetische Umgebung nicht reparieren?
Weil sie daran nicht interessiert sind.
Oder sie hätten den Leuten vor langer Zeit von diesem Zeug erzählt.
Sie studierten Verkehr und testeten Menschen dafür auf ihre wissenschaftlichen Fähigkeiten in den Bereichen Bioinformatik und Genomik.
Sobald Ihr Körper diese elektromagnetischen Signale nicht mehr umwandeln kann, ist das unnatürlich, es geht zu viel Energie im Blut, in den Knochen und in Ihrem Gefäßsystem verloren.
Irgendwann schwächt es die Venen, die Arterien, die Haut, und dann hast du Probleme.
Also tust du so, als würdest du dich im Wald verirren?
Bist du in den Untergrund gegangen?
War nur ein Scherz.
Also das haben sie getan.
Niemand hat die Wahrheit gesagt.
Stingray und die Strafverfolgung wurden 1972 abgeschlossen.
Also wurde ich vom Polizeichef mit meinem Gehirn oder, verzeihen Sie mir, meiner damaligen Schnittstelle zum Maschinenkörper benutzt, weil sie immer noch einen Lerntisch mit Nanolipid oder Hydrogel haben mussten, damit sie es durchgehen und auf einem Monitor zeigen konnten.
Das sind all diese Wachen.
Seit 2005 sind also alle still und kommerziell erhältlich.
Und auch hier ist der neue Standard für Cybersicherheit ein Wide Body Area Network, das möglicherweise an einem Personal Area Network beteiligt ist oder nicht, an dem Ihr iPad und alles andere beteiligt sein kann oder auch nicht.
Die Cybersicherheit genau hier, Februar 2022, zum sechsmal offenen digitalen Ausweis Routing und die digitalen Ideen, die aus Ihrem Telefon gemacht wurden.
Das ist richtig.
Häufigkeit und Wohnort Ihres was?
Ihr durch DNA generiertes elektromagnetisches, drahtlos zugängliches Körperteil seit 2005 kommerziell zugänglich.
Sie werden Sie nie darüber informieren, dass Ihr Arzt es nicht zugeben wird.
Du wirst lernen.
Wir werden darüber reden.
Und wenn du es versuchst.
Aber mach dich lustig über dich.
Warum?
Wollt ihr nicht totale Kontrolle und Menschen und sie auf Fernbedienungen haben, damit sie tun, was immer ihr wollt?
Kein freier Wille, keine Fähigkeit zu denken.
Ich hab's dir gesagt.
Neuronale Milderung mit subtilem.
Was nochmal?
Verhaltensänderung.
Noch einmal.
Vitalfunktionen, Atmung.
Einfach.
ACG-Überwachungsmonitor, Glukose-Hörgerät.
Welchen nichtmedizinischen Nutzen hat das, was Sie sich durch die Knochen stecken?
Denn wenn sie das tun, müssen Ihre roten Blutkörperchen nach dem Routing arbeiten und sie werden diese, entschuldigen Sie mich, diese Mineralien, die mir schwer auf der Schulter liegen, magnetisch direkt aus Ihrem Blutkreislauf ziehen.
Nun, Video-Streaming-Daten, Dateiübertragung, Sport, 3D, Video, vergessene Dinge, Monitor.
Und dann darfst du noch einmal drei Dinge tun: Unterhaltungsanwendungen, PR und Gaming sowie soziale Netzwerke.
Ich fange an zu sehen, wie das Metaversum das Internet der Dinge, das Internet der Körper und das Cyber-Internet der Dinge elektrozeutisch macht.
Es ist alles in deinem Gehirn miteinander verknüpft, da, hier.
Also, als ich versuchte, Leuten von Blood Projects zu erzählen, wie ich bin, und du musstest diesen Körperteil verstehen und wenn du nicht anfängst, damit zu arbeiten, fängst du an, es herauszufinden.
Das ist Drohnenkrieg.
Du wirst darauf warten, niemand.
Was Sie also tun müssen, ist zu verstehen, dass das Einzige, was Sie im Moment haben, zuerst die Physiologie ist, also zuzugeben, dass es der Körperteil ist.
Sie haben es für totale menschliche Versklavung getroffen und sie haben es.
Das ist unglaublich, das alles wurde in der Polizei gemacht, in den Abteilungen des Sheriffs.
Wie ich schon sagte, sie sind 1972 fertig und können mit synthetischer Telepathie und einem Haufen kleiner Kinder miteinander sprechen.
Und dann, als wir Teenager waren, kam der Rest, und 2013 wurde Brain Chip Interface eingeführt.
Beruflich wissen die Leute das immer noch nicht.
Sie denken immer noch, dass du einen echten Chip in deinem Gehirn brauchst.
Das tust du nicht.
Sie kaufen einfach eine Nano-Antenne mit der richtigen Frequenz für das Wide Body Area Network.
Es ist ungefähr hundert Dollar und dann kaufst du ein tragbares Gerät für 200$, das synthetische Telepathie erzeugt, das einfach subtil in deine Hirnnerven eindringt und es dir ermöglicht, alle Signale um dich herum zu hören, die auf diese Netzwerke projiziert werden.
Diese Netzwerke sind mit allem im Internet der Dinge, im industriellen Internet der Dinge und im Cyber-Nano-Internet der Körper verbunden und machen sich für sie über Ihre Internetkörper lustig.
Als ob du die Spezifität nicht kennst, dann musst du es wissen, denn dann sagten sie, Oh, aber das ist nur in Krankenhäusern.
Und ich sage, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das ist einfach albern, ich meine, ich meine, das ist ein Ingenieurentwurf.
Warum würdest du es nur im Krankenhaus lassen?
Ich meine, es würde nicht einmal so funktionieren.
Es ist komplett drahtlos, inklusive Satellit.
Also wählt diese Drohne deine DNA, weil MQ Nine an dich gebunden ist.
Denken Sie daran, dass ich gerade darauf hingewiesen habe und ich gehe zu MQ Nine.
10.
September 2020.
Künstliche Intelligenz Pentagon MQ Nine ist an den Boden gebunden Project Maven Project Pathfinder mit Objekterkennung.
Das ist richtig.
In einem kognitiven Körperbereich werden Netzwerke immer verwirrter, weil sie ein sogenanntes gegnerisches Netzwerk verwenden und Sie angreifen.
Weil sie zuschauen.
Sie denken mit diesen Kommentaren kognitiv für kognitive Radarbeobachtung, denken Sie in Echtzeit.
Und es taucht in einem winzigen Outfit auf und sie klicken auf einen Knopf.
Sie haben einen Herzinfarkt und einen Schlaganfall oder was auch immer sie wollen, jedes Molekül, jeder Zustand, mit dem wir konfrontiert werden, es steht ihnen alles seit 2005 zur Verfügung.
Oh, das absolute Minimum.
Meine Eltern hatten dieses Verfahren, es ist also 1969.
Jedes Molekül auf dem Planeten, überall.
Also, wie sind wir hierher gekommen?
Wie ist das alles zustande gekommen?
Keine mentale Rechenschaftspflicht, keine Verlogenheit, nichts.
Wir lassen sie einfach zuerst damit durchkommen.
Sie haben auf subtile Weise einen Stromschlag erlitten.
Viele Menschen bekamen Fibromyalgie, aber niemand wusste es.
Ich sagte, ein Tumor ist, wenn Sie einen Tumor haben, aber wir können ihn physisch nicht finden.
Es ist nur so, als ob dein Gehirn sich benimmt, als wäre es ein Pseudoanfall.
Also, meine Güte, wir wissen nicht, warum du dann so viele Anfälle hast.
Lupus, Lou-Gehrig-Syndrom, eine Autoimmunerkrankung von 80% Ihres Immunsystems befindet sich in diesem unsichtbaren Körperteil in 40 bis 60% Ihres endokrinen Systems.
Deshalb können all die Hormone niemals unter Kontrolle gebracht werden.
Sie machen ständig Probleme mit der elektrischen Übertragung der grundlegenden Zellstruktur Ihres größten Organs.
Kommt schon, Leute.
Und dann tun sie es nicht.
Krankheiten.
Oh, ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Das tun sie.
Die Weltgesundheitsorganisation hat zugegeben, dass Krebs nicht meine Geschichte ist, weshalb ich sie offen lasse.
Also viele Menschen haben das schon bei Krebs herausgefunden.
Sie sagen, Moment, ich bin krank, dass du willst, dass ich jetzt Chemo nehme?
Wie was?
Und ja, also nicht Mr.
Endo, aber jetzt sind wir schon beim Sudden Adult Death Syndrom angelangt.
Mensch, wir wissen nicht warum.
Und wenn sie sich zu viel bewegen und Sauerstoff in den roten Blutkörperchen umgewandelt wird, ist zu viel zufällig zu viel Radar von den Amazon-Versanddiensten.
Nur reguläre Unternehmen legen zu viel Wert auf Sicherheit.
Vielleicht ist es nur ein normales Unternehmen, das Geologie oder die Spitze eines Felsbogens oder was auch immer ausbaggert und jetzt aus Ihrem Körper zieht, um das Gebiet zu scannen.
Auch hier ist es nur Teil einer Arbeitsgruppe für drahtlose Sensoren hier oben von ATO, 2.1, 5.5 und Punkt vier.
Aber jetzt benutzt es deinen Körper, weil du in, du weißt schon, 2.1, 5.6 bist.
Und für unsere Zwecke ist das statt des Stryker ein Satellit.
Sie braucht deinen Körper in acht oder 2,1, 5,6.
Das sind permanente Lebensdauersensoren, die seit 2005 im Handel erhältlich sind.
Und das Verteidigungsministerium verkauft Ihnen über die Datenbank Zugriff auf unsere Volkszählung und Doppler und Hitze und Licht und wo Sie leben und mit wem Sie sprechen.
Deshalb war der ganze Grund, der mich hierher geführt hat, als mir klar wurde, dass mein Bezirk, egal in welcher Nähe ich wohne, meine kleine Stadt mit 200 Einwohnern, meinen Blutkreislauf durchsucht.
Das ist immer noch offen und das hat mich erschreckt.
Ich bin dem Link gefolgt und habe die Lesung also landesweit gemacht und wieder, das ist Februar 2022 für digital.
Ich bin über einen Geofencing gesprungen und habe Leute erwischt, damit sie ihren Geofence nicht verlassen können.
Aber hat dir niemand gesagt, dass du drahtlos bist, weil sie dir nicht die Fernsteuerung deines eigenen Körpers geben wollen.
Also, was wirst du dagegen tun, wenn das Radar auf dich trifft und sie mit ihrer DNA bereit ist, dich zu beenden?
Weil das die Aussage über tödliche autonome Waffen ist, die ich immer wieder aus dem College-Lehrbuch gelesen habe.
Ja.
Du kannst es also nicht hören, oder?
Ihr Körper wird es nicht hören, egal ob es sich um Drohnen oder Transdukte handelt.
Doch das ist ein Licht auf meinem Kanal, An Odyssey.
Es ist voll von Überlebenden elektromagnetischer Kriegsführung, Leuten wie mir, an denen dieses Zeug getestet und dann auf industrieller Ebene für die Defense Intelligence Agency, die NRO oder wen auch immer umgesetzt wurde.
Wir müssen jetzt verstehen, dass du keine Zeit hast, weil sie in den Krieg ziehen.
Und das machen sie seit 2005.
Und wieder war meine Familie 1969 dabei.
Also hier auf meinem Kanal unterrichte ich Biofilmpraxis, ich unterrichte Offensive und Defense.
Defensive ist großartig, weil du dich dann in deinem eigenen Bereich öffnest und lernst, wie man tatsächlich zuhört und atmet.
Aber letzte Woche gab es offensive Biofilm-Praxis, und ich habe zumindest vorgeschlagen, dass Sie es beobachten, bevor Sie es versuchen, und bevor Sie etwas tun, dass Sie wieder mit Ihrem Körper vertraut sind und all die Dinge korrigieren, die sie Ihnen falsch beigebracht haben, damit sie aus der Ferne auf Sie zugreifen und Ihr Immunsystem nehmen können, denn was passieren wird, sind die Plasmaladungen.
Und wenn Sie sich ansehen, dass 2030 darüber spricht, über diese Plasmaladungen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Elektromagnetischer Körperteil, du wirst es so oder so fühlen.
Aber wenn Sie Wissen im Voraus haben, werden Sie keine Angst haben und Sie werden besser darauf vorbereitet sein, Ihre Umgebung topologisch epigenetisch zu beobachten und die Menschen wirklich zu verstehen, die an all diesen wirklich bösen Dingen mitschuldig sind.
Sie werden dir sagen, dass deine Biofilme richtig beginnen, oder sie werden nicht darüber sprechen.
Und wenn sie dann an etwa zwei Dritteln beteiligt sind, geht es um die Zwecke dieses Landes.
Sie werden einfach so tun, als ob es egal ist und dass, oh, es mich nicht beeinflussen kann.
Ich glaube, das ist das Zentrum der Revolution.
Sie versuchen es mit unserem Land, weil unsere Jugend dieses Zeug biologisch gefährdet und sie wissen, wie einfach es ist, diese 400 Dollar zu kaufen und Telepathie zu haben und Menschen in Hollywood zu beeinflussen.
Sie machen das schon lange.
Nun, jetzt gehen sie noch einen Schritt weiter mit den Trends in der Gewebetechnik, der Vergrößerung.
Und ich sagte zu den Leuten, sie werden deine Armunterseite in Fische verwandeln.
Aber dann sagen sie, Oh, wir sind nicht zusammen.
Und jetzt ist es da.
Es gibt Ärzte da draußen, die anbieten, die DNA von Menschen zu verändern und sie in tierische Zustände umzuwandeln usw.
Ja, wir wissen, dass es jeden Tag eine Rolle spielt.
Okay, also Schritt eins, du musst ehrlich zu deiner Physiologie werden.
Du hast einen unsichtbaren Körperteil und jeder außer dir weiß es.
Das ist ein Problem.
Warum?
Weil dein Körper wichtig ist.
Der ganze Körper sofort.
Projizieren Sie jetzt dieses Feld.
Steamer-Sport.
Das war ganz.
Schauen wir uns die Verzerrung an, die tatsächlich so aussieht, als wäre es elektromagnetische Energie, nicht wahr?
Du hörst die Drohnen kommen.
Du wirst es fühlen.
Ihr Körper tut das natürlich.
Algore scheint für die Vögel da zu sein.
Das ganze Zeug notiert Leylines.
Das Militär benutzt sie schon lange.
Warum wusstest du es nicht?
Warum darfst du es nicht wissen?
Schritt eins Es ist dein Körperteil.
Schritt zwei: Mach es mit Gott richtig.
Gebet für Menschen, die wie einer sind.
Jesus.
Okay, nun, was auch immer du willst.
Physiologie.
Zuerst.
Es ist ein Körperteil und werde mit Gott ins Reine kommen.
Gebet dafür, dass Menschen alle Formen von Liebe repräsentieren.
Dann praktiziere Religionen, was auch immer.
Okay, die Hinweise sind getrennt.
Dass alles, woran du glaubst, die Pflicht ist, die dich liebt.
Zu wissen, dass es da draußen etwas Größeres gibt als dich selbst.
Das ist privat.
Das ist persönlich.
Deine Seele, souveränes Wesen in deiner Haut.
Super.
Okay.
Also für jeden, der Magnete mit Spannungsanpassung hatte, sie dann den Strafverfolgungsbehörden und der Geheimüberwachung übergeben und keine Ärzte, nichts.
Für wie viele Jahre?
Dann plötzlich, nachdem das Projekt sagt: Hör zu, ich sage: Oh mein Gott, wir haben so viele Probleme.
Katzen, Hunde und Goldfische.
Und da wurde ich dieses Jahr im April richtig munter.
Und ich sagte: Das Bubble Bitch, hier sind deine Venen und Arterien.
Ihnen geht es gut.
Jetzt ist alles in Ordnung.
Das heißt, sie geben sich nicht viel Mühe.
Aber so viel Aufwand.
Das ist.
Schauen Sie genau hin und schauen Sie sich dann an, wie die Biosphäre aussieht, wenn sie alle Erwartungen erfüllt.
Verdreht.
Verdammt.
Du drückst nicht ab.
Du wirst verdammt viel Glück haben, wenn du überhaupt zu meiner Tür kommst.
Und übrigens, Präkognition, wieder, das Buch, das ich dir gezeigt habe, Spinnen fressen damit.
Warum tun Sie immer noch so, als wären Sie nicht in ihrer Defense Intelligence Agency?
Pentagon-Datenbanken mit jedem Traum, den Sie haben, und dass Ihre Präkognition auch beobachtet wird, weil in Ihrem Gewebe.
Deshalb fressen Spinnen damit.
Das Gleiche gilt für Algore.
Es ist alles natürlich und jeder sagt immer, Oh, ich liebe es, in der Natur zu sein.
Warum all diese Kabel und Dinge?
Und ziemlich bald werden sie verschwinden.
Und die meisten Menschen wussten nicht, dass wir all dieses geputzte Atomplasma und den ganzen Rest davon hatten.
Wir hatten es im 19.
Jahrhundert und sie haben es für 150 Jahre weggenommen, damit sie dir dein Immunsystem zurückverkaufen und dich einsperren konnten.
Jetzt haben sie, wir haben Ihren Biokraftstoff und die bevorstehende elektromagnetische Kriegsführung nicht.
Du wirst nicht überleben.
So einfach ist das.
Also deine Chancen jetzt und du hast nicht viel Zeit.
1953.
Was glaubst du, haben sie jetzt?
Du.
Und dann.